it's no secret everything seems to be
more expensive these days and in order
to make ends meet many are selling and
pawning off their things here locally
and all around the country madison
kimbrough stopped by a local shop today
she joins us live in our newsroom with
more on what customers are saying
madison
there was a steady clientele this
evening over at waukee gold and silver
buy shop as their manager shares that
they have seen an increase in higher
ticketed items coming through their door
as of late
i was looking at selling and
just a chain zachary lyford stepping
into waikiki gold and silver to sell a
memory he says he has to in order to
make ends meet this month he along with
so many others doing the same thing to
get extra cash fast with inflation
rising it's a terrible time when right
now that people really have to reflect
and decide where they need to go forward
and what they need to do and
unfortunately giving up some of their
prized possessions kind of where i'm at
right now you know giving up my class
ring is where it was kind of where we're
at waikiki gold and silver located on
las vegas boulevard is not a pawn shop
but a buy shop as they don't offer loans
or ponds so by selling your item they
will in turn own it outright and no
longer is it just those who come in to
make a little extra money for that new
fancy watch but instead they're seeing
people struggling to afford the
necessities it's people that need money
for sure people that are trying to pay
their rent people that are trying to
cover their cell phone bill or their car
payment manager william down says ever
since the pandemic hit they've seen an
increase in people coming in and the
items for sale are becoming grander in
scale more expensive items would come
through the door as opposed to
50
dollar items we would start seeing
thousand dollar three thousand dollar
items and for those like daquan alston
who is selling his xbox to help his
family out financially he acknowledges
that times are tough so for now this is
his best option it's not a main item
that i use every day you feel me i can
take time off of it so if it's going to
help somebody benefit in my house then
yeah i would do it
and so how much did those customers get
for their items well it ranged from 50
bucks to a couple hundred dollars in the
newsroom madison kimbrough live local
now